you
in the Korean culture body fat is very
unattractive if you're fat and crude
you're either two things you're either a
sumo wrestler or you're a bigger sumo
wrestler and that's it
I'm not fat I'm not fat I'm not fat I'm
not fat
uh who said I was fat because that's
more of an opinion based a logic of
wasn't a gobble day so I don't day for a
couple years now and there's two things
you never ever want to mention round
them one it looks at the chubby Chinese
kid who sings Whitney Houston
and - you never want to mention the
effort around him back Eddie we're boys
right mm-hmm sure have been for a while
um talk about pretty much anything okay
okay cool um could you uh put them
behind less you down
what's they gone please okay fine but
okay that's part of it's part of what I
want to talk to you about you've been
eating a lot more McDonald's and other
stuff recently in that let's talk for a
second and why don't you go ahead and
get in point because you've got to be
another bush okay okay so case in point
uh this t-shirt you're wearing
what about there's things a little tight
I mean I could see every I've had this
shirt for years and you've never
complained about it before so I really
don't understand what the whole point
was comes well good before I couldn't
see your diaphragm when you breathe well
I'm getting a hit that you call me fat
so I suggest you watch your words right
now are you calling me fat
I'm not calling fat not calling me I'm
saying you can see my diaphragm through
my church which I don't know if it my
coffee Shack you take honey much I put
in the money magnifies the point that is
part of the point O this is
time-sensitive stuff okay you can get
one - you don't need honey much that's a
cultural thing see is that all this is
yes this is just about my race it's not
much race it is if I'm black uh let me
ask you this is Barney fat is the
Michelin tire man fat is Oprah fat no
that's just the way they are and in that
same respect you should judge my body
the same way if a tree fell in the
middle of a forest and no one was around
to hear it does that make me fat so
after that fight David's are ducking my
calls I call the cell phone I called his
house phone i facebooked him I tweeted
the fat bastard
and how do I know
hi this is David and I'm currently not
the phone right now and if this is
negombo
you're our senior halt looking askance
up Manette son piece oh yeah he knew he
knew I'm no heating you
he knew we're gonna work out that's why
the next day I showed to his house
unannounced
you know which quarry Oh baby oh he was
here uh he eats a gene he working out
like you saying today it's a good boy
yeah you know that one he's a courageous
you know what I don't think he should
have hit me uh and it wasn't my fault
I refuse to work out I'm just not gonna
do it working out is stupid it's stupid
okay
the only reason why you would have to
have muscles is viewer caveman or you
lived in Africa which he probably could
have
oh he's here right now
talk to you later